[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le débat
politique sur rt france alors que
françois fillon a été lourdement
condamnée cette semaine
l'indépendance de la justice fait débat
la droite est vent debout contre le
parquet national financier accusé d'être
une officine du pouvoir lundi l'ancien
candidat à la présidentielle a été
condamné à cinq ans de prison dont deux
ferme et 10 ans d'inégibilité trois ans
avec sursis pour son épouse dans cette
affaire des emplois fictifs de pénélope
fillon
le couple devra en plus rembourser plus
d'un million d'euros à l'assemblée
nationale et payer 750 mille euros est
d'amande pour en débattre ce soir nous
sommes avec lydia guirous ce ancien
porte parole et républicains bonsoir
lydia guirous ce et nous sommes
également avec georges kuzmanovic
fondateur de république souveraine
bonsoir georges kuzmanovic
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
avec nous sur rt france on va regarder
d'abord les réactions les républicains à
cette condamnation de françois fillon
cette semaine ils se sont dits
stupéfaits de la sévérité de la justice
regardez soutien amical à françois
fillon
stupéfait de la sévérité de la décision
rendue par le tribunal correctionnel
persuadé que l'appel permettra de faire
la lumière sur la procédure et notamment
le rôle du pnf on ne peut s'empêcher de
penser que la déflagration de cette
condamnation est destinée à couvrir le
bruit des révélations sur une procédure
manifestement entièrement à charge la
condamnation terriblement lourdes à
l'encontre de françois fillon s'inscrit
dans la continuité d'un scénario
politico judiciaire dont on connaissait
l issue avant même le dénouement est le
début ils devaient être coupable
c'était écrit d'avancé je redis mon
amitié à françois fillon
voilà c'était écrit d'avancé l'ida games
vous êtes d'accord avec ces réactions
est ce que la procédure contre françois
fillon a été menée à charge et très
rapidement c'est ce qu'on a reproché au
parquet national financiers
moi j'ai pas l'habitude de critiquer les
décisions de justice j'ai envie de
croire en l'indépendance de la justice
en france
néanmoins il est vrai que ça a été
extrêmement rapide dans cette affaire
fillon pendant la présidentielle
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
fait que cette affaire est assez
exceptionnel jeu je pense que ce n'est
pas sain pour notre démocratie que de
critiquer et de de remettre en question
une décision de justice françois fillon
va a fait appel et j'espère que la
justice fera son travail avec lui comme
avec n'importe quel citoyen il n'est ni
au dessus des lois n'y ni en dessous il
doit être traité comme n'importe quel
citoyen alors l'ancien garde des sceaux
rachida dati parle de d'officine en
parlant du parquet national financier à
candide ou georges kuzmanovic est ce que
c'est une justice aux ordres de
l'exécutif ou pas je parle du parquet
national financière mais de manière
générale je suis d'accord avec ce que le
dit avec bruce c'est une décision
logique si ça a été prise et c'est assez
gros certaine manière et en même temps
un petit peu compréhensible de voir le
camp des républicains se mobiliser pour
défendre l'un des leurs mais il faut
quand même rappeler que le parquet
national financier a été créée après
laffaire cahuzac et que nous sommes dans
un pays où on a un très très très grande
très grande difficulté à punir la mettre
en prison
en particulier les hommes politiques
mais aussi des grands fraudeurs fiscaux
contrairement à d'autres pays
contrairement aux états unis donc mais
ce n'est pas une officine ses 107 ce
parquet national financier est censé
lutter contre la fraude fiscale contre
la corruption contre contre les délits
boursiers ce qu'il fait ils doivent
faire le faire beaucoup plus je pense
qu'on devrait lui attacher la protection
des entreprises stratégiques
quand on utilise l'argument de la
corruption pour les pour les saisir je
pense par exemple aux états unis
lorsqu'ils achètent alstom volant ce
qu'ils attaquent ils attaquent airbus
mais il a peut être une chose qui est
vrai c'est que
peut-être se parquer finances nationales
financier devrait être indépendant et ne
pas dépendre du parquet général de paris
parce que le parquet général de paris
dépend lui de l'autorité de l'exécutif
donc dépendu du ministre de la justice
donc dépens de l'elysée et c'est vrai
que tous les soupçons sont ouverts mais
qu'on a cette chaîne de commandement on
devrait avoir un grand une grande
instance nationale de lutte contre la
corruption et la fraude fiscale voilà je
pense que c'est vers ça qu'on devrait
attendre et qui ne dépendent pas
directement du ministre et d'exécutif
alors voilà remanié en tout cas cette
redonner un peu plus d'indépendance au
pnf ce pnf en tout cas là là la
procureure national du parquet financier
eliane houlette souvenez vous le 10 juin
a bien admis qu'elle avait subi quelques
pressions en tout cas dans dans
l'avancée de ce dossier on va écouter ce
qu'a répondu justement sa supérieure
hiérarchique à l'époque cette semaine
devant la commission d'enquêté de
l'assemblée nationale sur l'indépendance
de la justice écouter les jeunes aient
reçu dans la sphère fillon comme dans
tous les autres dossiers relevant de mon
contrôle hiérarchique aucune instruction
de la dncg aucune instruction du pouvoir
exécutif et quincy je n'ai jamais jamais
relayé une demande du garde des sceaux
ou du pouvoir exécutif pour influer sur
le traitement des procédures
le procureur général s'arroge un droit
de regard sur la conduite et les choix
d'action publique
des procureurs de la république en tout
cas je je je ne parle qu'en mon nom et
ce droit de regard est omniprésent il se
traduit par des demandes de rapports des
copies de copies de réquisitoire
définitif dès qu'ils sont transmis au
juge d'instruction des demandes de
précisions et lorsqu'une personnalité
politique est mise en cause de contrôle
est extrêmement étroits alors lorsque
personnalités politiques et mis en cause
ça remonte automatiquement en tout cas
au procureur général du parquet lydia
guirous c'est une coutume
normal mais ça arrive aussi aux oreilles
de l'exécutif est ce que ça c'est normal
selon vous la question c'est
véritablement celle de l'indépendance de
ce pays n'est fait et l'autre l'autre
sujet c'est quand même là les fuites qui
l'y a sans arrêt notamment dans la
presse le secret de l'instruction n'est
n'est pas respectée ce n'est pas normal
qu on retrouve dans certains médias
l'ensemble des éléments sur une enquête
en cours et c'est ça qui ne permet pas
d'avoir des décisions une enquête
sereine le bnf a été mise en place suite
aux à la sphère cahuzac c'était pour
donner un peu de confiance après 7,7
cette affaire qui était quand même un
big bang avec ce ministre qui avait juré
les yeux dans les yeux
la main sur le coeur à l'assemblée
nationale qu'il n'avait pas fraudé pour
rétablir la confiance envers la classe
politique a été créé ce pnr
donc je pense qu'il faut pas le
supprimer mais que leurs efforts mais
pour le rendre plus indépendant et sous
surtout que cesse dans ces affaires là
mais aussi dans d'autres affaires qui
concernent des personnalités publiques
que l'on retrouve dans une certaine
facile en sont des éléments de
l'instruction et des et des enquêtes qui
sont en cours parce que ça ça me ça mais
ça ne permet pas de garantir une
sérénité une égalité de traitement et et
c'est quelque chose qui va qu'il va
falloir revoir assez assez rapidement et
concernant et eliana houlette est là
elle avait elle avait indiqué ne pas
avoir subi de pression puis indiqué
avoir subi des pressions tu es revenu
sur ses propos
donc je ne sais pas quoi penser il faut
faire attention aussi à ne pas tomber
dans une forme de dictature de la
transparence qui va paralyser l'ensemble
de l'action publique ne pas permettre
d'avoir les meilleurs éléments qui
s'engagent en politique je je trouve
qu'il ya une une ligne de crête qui est
qui qui est assez je te je trouve
quelque chose de très sensible sur ces
questions là et que
l'indépendance la garantie du secret de
l'égalité de traitement qu'on soit
personnalités publiques ou pas est
quelque chose de fondamental et qui à ce
jour n'est pas encore totalement garanti
est ce que c'est
est ce que le problème georges kiejman
au vide ce n'est pas et d'ailleurs ça a
été soulevée par des instances
européennes et internationales que
justement le procureur général est nommé
par la garde des sceaux le garde des
sceaux l'exécutif donc est ce que là
aussi il faudrait qu'il y ait une
réforme pour modifier ce mode de
nomination pour donner plus
d'indépendance au parquet écoutez le
parquet est le bras armé judiciaire de
l'exécutif mais ce n'est pas
complètement insensé que de l'avoir par
contre il faut en parallèle et ça existe
partiellement une justice indépendante
et c'est pour ça que je réitère ce que
j'ai dit nouveau république souveraine
nous proposons que le parquet national
financier manière d'ailleurs que le
parquet national anti terroristes qui
sont les deux les deux instances avoir
une des compétences nationales soient
totalement indépendant et qui le comme
l'a dit linda de n'est pas cette chaîne
de commandement qui mène ou
la place vendôme au ministère de la
justice et qu'il n'est pas dans cette
chaîne de commandement les pertes qui
vont dans la presse parce que c'est là
que ça vient je ne pense pas que ça
vienne justement du parquet national
financiers ça vient des gens autant de
ministres et qui pour des raisons d
autres d'autres ont besoin de faire
fuiter ces informations à la presse on y
gagnerait considérablement pour faire
avancer parfois les dossiers et même à
la police ans est une pratique
effectivement assez courante on va
écouter ce que dit henri leclerc
l'avocat pénaliste justement sur cette
indépendance du parquet ceux qui
contestent le parquet national
financiers ce sont ceux qui risquent
d'en sentir les effets le problème est
plus général
c'est celui de l'indépendance du parquet
qu'ils soient financiers ou anti
terroriste il faut repenser la structure
de la justice française donc il faut
bien repenser ce que vous disiez un
georges kiejman a vite je repensais les
deux parquet indépendant soit là et on
aura un pays si on a ces deux parquet
indépendant et en particulier sur cette
question que nous évoquons aujourd'hui
le parquet national financiers nous
répondrons à une des demandes du peuple
français qui s'est manifestée entre
autres avec les gilet jaune avec la
demande de justice fiscale et
l'incompréhension qu'une partie de la
population une certaine frange pas la
totalité évidemment permettre tous les
politiques sont dans le même sac mais
une frange est totalement immunisé à
toute attaque et peut faire ce qu'elle
veut et également une frange de très
très grands fraudeurs fiscaux qui se
joue des lois de la république et
nuisent à la vie ensemble au financement
des services publics
il faut avoir une instance qui soit en
mesure de les poursuivre et de les
sanctionner sévèrement et alors c'est le
cas on l'a vu en la sanction est assez
lourde avec françois fillon il y a aussi
le couple balkany on l'a vue qui a été
lourdement sanctionné pour vous ce n'est
ce n'est pas suffisant
georges kuzmanovic et même la même
question pour lydia guirous ce après
encore une fois je ne juge pas la
sanction est un séjour dura un appel
mais encore une fois avec monsieur
cahuzac qui a pris une sanction aussi
peu relativement lourd mais qui a été
commuée et qui finalement ça ne s'est
pas transformé en quelque chose de si
violent pour lui on a eu une sanction
effectivement contre monsieur balkany
mais il est sorti très très vite de
prison
on est encore loin des punitions qu'on
peut qu'on peut recevoir aux états unis
par exemple quand on fraude canton
fraudent le fisc des etats-unis quand
quand on est con non plus donc il serait
temps que et bien oui là quentin quand
un petit patron fait une fonte on ne
paye pas ses impôts il est sanctionné
immédiatement quand quelqu'un voilà
quelque chose il va en prison et bien là
c'est pareil a abandonné mais c'est une
question de confiance globale dans le
pays
il faut que ceux qui fraudent surtout
s'ils sont à la tête de l'état soient
sanctionnés c'est pas travaillé
également lydia guirous ce oui si on
food il faut il faut être sanctionné et
des remords que je prendrais pas
l'exemple des états unis c'est très
différent et manière générale je crois
pas qu'il faille regarder du côté des
états unis pour prendre s'inspirer pour
tout ce qui est question de justice et
d'autres et d'autres sujets je pense que
c'est les sanctions j'ai pas envie de
donner de soi dans le cas de patrick
balkany par les époux balkany ou fillion
ou même cahuzac je pense que la justice
a fait son travail va faire son travail
je pense que c'est très violent très
difficile à vivre et et que
l'indépendance voilà c'est le maître mot
en fac c'est l'indépendance c'est plus
que ce que supprimer le pnf c'est
vraiment le réformer pour pour le rendre
indépendant et que et que tous nous
soyons traités de la natation apprécié
lorsqu'on commet des erreurs qui peuvent
être réprimés par dans ce cadre là le
supprimer c'est ce que prône eric ciotti
effectivement le député d'aidé
peu maritime écoutez le il ya une passe
d'armes justement cette semaine à
l'assemblée avec la garde des sceaux le
pnf s'apparente de plus en plus à une
juridiction d'exception
cela n'est pas sain créé pour les
affaires financières complexes
il s'est transformé en lieu de tract
politique avec une prédilection et une
célérité particulière pour les opposants
et une lenteur et une clémence constante
pour les amis du pouvoir actuel et passé
il serait périlleux de vouloir
aujourd'hui supprimé le parc national
financier le parquet national financier
le pnf est devenu un instrument majeur
de notre souveraineté judiciaire
les succès qui ont été obtenues dans les
négociations sur airbus sur google et je
pourrais citer bien d'autres dossiers en
font aujourd'hui un acteur
incontournable reconnu dans sa
légitimité son expertise en france comme
à l'international
une juridiction d'exception les mots
sont assez fort georges kiejman au beach
mais souvenons nous guette d'affaires
colère également cette lettre d'
emmanuel macron qui a permis un
classement sans suite
c'est pas d'intrusion ça bon d'abord je
suis très étonné que madame bello mais
trouve que ce que le pnr est obtenu un
succès sur airbus ont encore une fois il
s'est plutôt contraire on a subi à
nouveau une atteinte à notre
souveraineté de la part des états unis
et d'ailleurs quand tout à l'heure je
citais les états unis s'étaient pas
comme modèle c'est parce que tous ces
gens là si elle fait régulièrement et
que quand même dans ce pays l'a senti la
justice peut être un peu plus dur pour
leurs propres ressortissants et la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale
il est bien meilleur qu'en france mais
quand même un million des mondes pour
google ça c'est pas une réussite
un million d'arbres pour google je crois
que c'est moins que vous si on donnait
demandé de verser un centime de monde un
peu plus
je pense que c'est vraiment beaucoup
moins que ça même donc c'est à dire 1
millions pour google c'est dans une
farce
en tout cas par rapport aux questions
que vous posiez non le lui le encore une
fois le parquet national financier doit
être indépendant monsieur ciotti est
très amusant il se rend compte des
choses souvent après coup il découvre
que amende de policiers
monsieur sarkozy qui équipaient d'élite
qui a réduit le nombre de policiers
il est chaud prick commandes de comment
commandes comment que de masques alors
qu'il a voulu les politiques
néolibérales qui font commandes de
masques et de production nationale
industrielle et là il dit que le pdf est
de facto au service du pouvoir politique
est bien quelque part comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure qu'il a raison il faut
tout simplement que ce parquet national
financier soit indépendant est comme ça
si un jour éventuellement les
républicains prennent le pouvoir
ils n'auront pas pnf à leur solde qui
fera le travail qu'il fait peut-être
actuellement pour le pouvoir en place et
c'est vrai que le pnf existe depuis
françois hollande donc la droite n'a pas
eu l'occasion en tout cas de d'avoir à
faire directement si tant est si tel est
le cas avec le pnf lydia guirous selon
le mot de la fin pour vous quand eric
ciotti par une juridiction d'exception
quand cette lettre d' emmanuel macron
qui a permis à alexis colère de
peut-être un de ne pas être poursuivi
qu'en pensez vous alors concernant la
lettre je ne suis pas sûr que cette
lettre est une véritable lors des essais
jeu et puis concernant les mots d'eric
ciotti
elles ne seront pas les miens à ma
position est considéré qu' aujourd'hui
le pnf doit surtout à gagner son
indépendance et qui doit être réformé
plus que supprimer
et je crois que ça passerait extrêmement
mal auprès de l'opinion publique
si on en venait à supprimer le pm est le
pnf et qui aurait une défiance des
français qui nierait que crescendo
vis-à-vis de la classe politique
il pourrait considérer avec cette
suppression que c'est une caste qui
essaye de se protéger et donc je pense
que c'est une mauvaise chose que de
vouloir supprimer le pennec
en revanche le réformer le rendre
totalement indépendant c'est la voix qui
sont absolument suivre de manière
urgente
merci
koua a tous les deux on n'a pas le temps
malheureusement d'aborder la sphère des
écoutes de nicolas sarkozy ce sera
l'objet d'un autre débat merci à tous
les deux en tout cas d'avoir participé à
celui ci c'est la fin de ce débat
politique rester avec nous sur rt france